uh very pleased to say uh that i'm
joined in the studio uh by the
chancellor of the exchequer
rishi sooner uh mr soon i as mentioned
you are about my second live
face-to-face interview in six months so
i will try occasionally to be gentle and
and we will be talking about donald
trump in just a moment
um but but i wonder if we might begin
with with test and trace
clearly this was something as the health
secretary admitted yesterday
should not have happened can you please
concede that because of this mistake
there is a likelihood that there will be
people in
in the united kingdom who have
contracted covid19
as a result well good morning and i
think
the health secretary was very clear
yesterday and i agree with him this
should absolutely not have happened and
that's why an
investigation has been launched i think
the most important thing to focus on now
is
you know what are we doing to fix the
situation as
we heard yesterday people worked over
the weekend
over half of those who had been tested
were put into the contact racing system
as of for 9am
yesterday morning obviously that would
have been improved since then
and it's important to know a couple of
things to your specific question i think
the chief medical officer
and the jbc are sent to the looks of all
of this have said that the numbers don't
impact uh substantially the the
assessment of the
virus and the measures that were taken
last week and in particular
and specifically for care homes schools
and hospitals
that is not impacted because that system
works slightly differently to this
so those things have happened that those
things have happened
as that specifically is not when i asked
though because of this mistake
there is a strong likelihood testing
trace was set up to try and halt
transmission
in the community it failed there is a
very strong likelihood that some people
will have contracted covid19
there is also a possibility that some
people might have died as a result of
this
well i think you're right in the sense
that there has been a delay in people
being contacted and the health secretary
was very clear about that yesterday
what as soon as the situation came to
light i think uh
several thousand extra man hours over
the weekend went in
to getting in touch with all those
people as of nine am yesterday morning
we know just over half had been
contacted for a second time
to catch up with where we should have
been you're absolutely right i don't
have an updated number on that but
obviously it would have improved
considerably from yesterday morning
the most important thing now is to try
and get through that as quickly as
possible and
very good progress was made over the
weekend i understand why no politician
would ever wish to concede that they had
put people's lives at risk but
demonstrably that is what has happened
here
reports of the world beating nature of
our testing trace system have clearly
been greatly exaggerated
and we're going to be spending 12
billion pounds on this it's not value
for money
well i think that's probably not
completely fair if you think back to
where we were
i think we were doing at the beginning
of this crisis a few thousand tests a
day maybe at most 10 000 right at the
beginning of this
crisis if you look at where we were a
couple of days ago
the 250 000 tests were carried out a
couple of days ago
300 000 capacity uh and with a clear
trajectory to get that up to almost half
a million by the end of october
and so 4000 covered 19 positive you said
yes we have spell
spent 12 billion pounds right you know
where has that gone it's gone on
taking up test capacity from 10 000 a
day to
250 on to half a million but also that
puts us now in
ahead of most almost all european
countries in terms of our ability to
test and every day
is it perfect no are we continuing to
bet make it better
yes but i think it's worth taking a
moment to just recognize the progress
that has been made and i'm happy to let
give you that opportunity but at the
same time 4 000 covered 19 positive
people
went more than a week without being
contacted by tests and traits
it's not exactly not perfect of course
but that is a failure
and at this time when we are spending so
much money on it
i think people want to hear a government
minister concede that
well i think government ministers and
indeed died of harding have said very
clearly at times when the system has
been under stress that's not
something that we want to see that's why
we're putting the extra resources in as
you said 12 billion pounds
the number of tests have gone up
considerably from the beginning they're
continuing to ramp up
and the performance metrics are
improving we now you know it's just
i think on average when i last saw no
one is going on average more than about
four miles
for a test the vast majority of tests
are coming back the next day
and the testing capacity and tests
carried out are ramping up every day
that's all good progress you're right
there's more to do and i can assure you
it remains a number one priority of
focus for us
i suppose the problem with the
government is this very similar to the
situation as with a levels people were
warning you
about the problems with the excel
spreadsheet the problems with putting
outdated hardware running
outdated software at the crunch point in
terms of getting the data
into the system joanna vienna fellow in
epigenetics at the university of
birmingham said this
when we started at the lighthouse labs
in march in march
we advised against analyzing the results
in excel and said
multiple times they should recruit
bioinformaticians to deal with the data
why was all that why were we faffing
around with excel
when the scientists were telling us not
to well i think also that the system
we've designed has been designed in
conjunction with our scientists we have
a huge degree of certain number of
scientists who are involved directly
with the government designing these
things
implementing them making sure they work
whether that's at the jbc
the joint biosecurity center or indeed
public health england
they're also all scientists who've been
involved in in developing this and i
just go back to whatever so they're not
people who could have pointed out if
you're running an
outdated version of excel you couldn't
import this data they're all people who
are experts in data
who are engaged in implementing this
product doing their job then clearly and
i think
again take a step back we've gone from
10 000 a day to 250 000 a day we're up
by the way 40 or 50 from the summer so
even just more recently the trajectory
has ramped up
we're on a path for half a million by
the end of october
and and the percentages of people have
been contacted as quickly as we'd like
continue to be strong and are improving
i wonder if we could talk about the eat
out to help out a scheme that many
people took advantage of and i was
admit that i certainly did myself but do
you accept
as the prime minister did at the weekend
that eat out to help out might have
contributed to the spread
of covert 19. i'm sure that's exactly
what the prime minister said he said in
general
as far as hospitality is a source of
transmission
that's why we should make sure we focus
our attention on it to suppress the
spread of the virus which is why there
are things like table service only
the curfew etc in place but i think more
broadly if you think about
the the spread of the virus this time
around what's happening here
is is pretty much in sync with what's
happening around the world in second
waves whether it's france or spain where
very specifically our scientists said we
were following
exactly the same curve so actually there
seems to be more feature just of the
virus and the season than anything
specific
and then on the scheme itself i mean if
you look at where it was used uh almost
the most uh relevant in reference to the
size of the population the southwest
probably stands out
and indeed the southwest today is the
region with some of the
lowest covered incidences anywhere in
the country
probably helped england data also shows
between the 14th of august and the 20th
of september eating out was the most
commonly reported activity in the two to
seven days prior to symptom onset
correlation perhaps not causation but if
you look at manchester
their case numbers were 32.5 per 100 000
the week ending the 27th of september
that number was over 200 per hundred
thousand the week of the second of
october it was over 500.
you can't say for certain 100 percent
that this scheme didn't contribute i i
think
you just were having a conversation
before about data science and you said
it there there's a big difference
between correlation and causation so i
would be i would be i guess cautious
about jumping to simplistic conclusions
there's also different data which also
using public health england data
uh which hospitality industry is also
analyzed and that showed
a very small percentage of hospitality
being a cause for transmissions i think
one thing
we know is and actually i speak to our
scientists almost every day
it's incredibly difficult at such a
granular level to pinpoint exactly the
cause of transmission
and so i think we should be you know we
should have some humility about our
ability to do that
do we know in general that social
contact is a cause of transmission
of course we do but that can also happen
inside households and whether in the
midlands where we've seen before
you know that was identified as the key
source of transmission was household
mixing inside homes
so it is going to be different depending
on where you are in the country the
exact source of
the virus spread will vary and that's
why our response
can be targeted in nuance to the
situation we confront
how are we going to get out of this from
from your speech yesterday it seemed
pretty clear that we're not going to be
seeing a return to
austerity to cuts to public services and
that really indicates only one thing
doesn't it
tax rises so the question is when do
they come and where do they fall
i think the priority right now is on
jobs and if
you look at the various steps i've been
taking indeed just a couple of weeks ago
with our winter economy plan
my overwhelming focus at the moment is
trying to protect
and support as many jobs as possible
what's happening in our economy is
significant and severe many people are
losing their jobs so the focus of all my
attention in the short term
is doing what we can to support as much
employment as possible
over time yes you're right we need to
have sustainable public finances
that's important to me it's important to
the government but in the short term
uh the best way to have long-term
sustainable public finance is to try and
protect as much employment as possible
sure but you can understand why people
listening to you yes they might wish to
know where you are focusing on in terms
of the tax rises that seem inevitable
given what you've just said and what you
said yes
and as every interview i do people would
like to know about tax and i give
exactly the same answer every time
i can't comment on future tax policy tax
policy is set at fiscal events
but i think people broadly should be
understanding that
my focus right now is protecting jobs
and employment that's why all the
various
things that we've put in place whether
it's supporting small businesses through
our new pay-as-you-growth scheme to help
restructure bounce-back loans
whether it's the green homes grant
program to help people insulate their
homes and generate activity whether it's
the kickstart scheme to help those
who are young and at risk of long-term
unemployment find job placements
all of that is targeted to the problem
at the moment which is supporting jobs
when you say that we we should be living
without fear right now
what do you mean by that i mean it's
it's fair enough for you know
fit rich good looking 40 year old to say
live without fear
but for those who have lost their jobs
or are about to lose their jobs or
perhaps in one of
the shielding categories it doesn't
resonate it's almost trumpian
we heard this from donald trump in fact
last night
he said don't be afraid of the virus yes
and you also heard from the prime
minister live fearlessly but with
common sense and i fully agree with that
i think it's important that we
maintain some degree of confidence and
optimism about our future
and actually that has an impact on our
economic performance you talk about jobs
actually if we have no confidence and
indeed this is a
consumer-driven economy uh consumption
drives a large part of economic activity
in this country if people don't have
confidence to do those things
that will actually have a direct impact
on people losing their jobs
and it's because of that that i'm so
keen to make sure that we can try and
maintain as much economic activity as
possible that's not an abstract concept
that's about protecting those jobs that
you spoke about and yes you're right
for those people who are losing those
jobs that is tragic it's something
that i feel very deeply and i want to
make sure that we provide all of those
people
with fresh hope and opportunity which is
why our initiatives and new
apprenticeships new training
our kickstart scheme are so important
mentioned a comparison with donald trump
a second ago in terms of the language
that's used another thing that both you
and he seem
very fond of doing is putting your name
on everything admittedly with him it's
on terms of towers
with you it's in terms of the political
advertising we have a look
there have been an awful lot of adverts
over the past few weeks
with your name on with your face on
with the greatest respect you're you're
not the prime minister
so it does almost look just the
teensiest best narcissistic
uh no actually i'm i'm very new to
politics in that sense and actually for
someone who has a job like mine
uh where i'm responsible for the uk
economy i'm not someone who's been in
politics for a very long time and
actually understandably most people
probably didn't know who i was before i
had this job and maybe they don't know
you aren't known
and that's that's exactly the point
right my job is
to make sure that everyone in this
country understands what i'm doing on
their behalf
can question it hold me accountable for
it and feel engaged with that debate
now that that's easier for them to do
that if their politician apart from a
prime minister whoever sticks their name
their personal branding over their
policy announcements
well i think that's that's we're
actually living in a world where people
can communicate in different ways
my main my main desire is to make sure
everyone understands what i'm doing so
they can question it hold me account for
it
know why i'm doing it and i'm going to
try lots of different ways to
communicate with people i'm not going to
apologize for that i want people to know
what we're up to and so that they can
question it and
decide whether they like it don't like
it either way that's the right they have
you mentioned the us actually the vast
majority
of senior politicians in the us take an
approach to social media
which is very similar you just mentioned
one but actually
lots of other politicians and i would go
into a long list of them which most
people may not have even heard
but not over here but the point is the
same but the point is the one about
communication
i mean this is one form of communication
and you'll have your listeners at home
who are watching this
there'll be lots of other people who
might have tuned into a linkedin q a i
did last week
particularly focused on small business
there will be others who see
one of my explainers on youtube
explaining one of our policies and what
it's trying to achieve
but again if if people feel that they
know who's doing it and engage with the
content
it's going to make for a much more
informed debate in this country around
our economic policy and that's something
i'm very keen to see happen
the reason people focus on it is because
often it is suggested that at some point
in the not too distant future
you might fancy making the move from
number 11 to number 10
at times like that brand reinforcement
is very very useful you did say
yesterday
that you would definitely not be running
for the leadership i'm just wondering
given the number of u-turns this
government has performed whether we can
trust you entirely on that
yeah as i said yesterday uh i think this
the job i have is
hard enough and i see up close the uh
what the prime minister has to deal with
every day
it's not an envious task i think he does
it admirably well
these are very difficult times i'm
grateful
that we have his leadership i think the
country should be very grateful for that
as well
and you know i'm just trying to focus on
the job by hand the job i have which as
we talked about
is it's a very difficult time to be
doing my job hundreds of thousands of
people
are losing their jobs as we speak uh
many more will
that's happening on my watch and i need
to try and do what i can
to provide fresh opportunity for people
and protect as many of those jobs as
possible it's
plenty for me to be focused on yeah
certainly no one not even your
arch political enemies which suggest you
have anything other than a very very
difficult job at the moment so thank you
for taking the time today
thank you very much good to see